est-ce que tu es prêt pour une interview
bisounours
[Musique]
vous avez quel âge pour être premier
bisous
la semaine dernière pourquoi je
me suis coincé dans une
la pâquerette et
[Rires]
ben vous avez attendu longtemps votre
virginité une jeune fille
12 ans
c'est quoi la soirée des Halles à deux
pour vous
elle et moi c'est tout sans personne
d'autre
vous préférez quand harry rencontre
sally une nuit blanche à Seattle
quelle est la chose la plus romantique
que vous ayez fait dans votre vie
offrir des fleurs
c'est quand la dernière fois qu'une
femme vous a bien sûr
il y a 6 mois voilà elle a fait quoi a
pas fait grand-chose mais elle a fait
ça t'a blessé
c'est un détail pour vous mais
ce soir il est dans la salle ce soir il
fait france gall soirée thématique
soirée thématique
[Rires]
c'est dans les bras de qui vous sentez
le mieux
c'est quoi définition de l'amour
je la cherche encore
peluche favorite c'est laquelle
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça balance pas mal à Paris
jamais osé dire je t'aime
à ma fille
on t'envoie un petit bisou
là.
[Musique]